brive n'a pour tout comme un oiseau
[Musique]
wade ton coeur est juste si tu
t'entraînes toi aussi tu peux être x man
les x men c'est pas ma canne mais alors
pas du tout parce que tout d'abord on
m'a déjà des puces les jeux le
protégerait contre câbles mais tout seul
je peux pas je suis à x man ta gueule tu
as tout est si longue du crâne justin
bieber t'as vu ta prise pour justin
bieber est pas rien
dès qu'un bouffon
déguisé en voit tellement d'arc tu es
sûr que tu viens pas le nez vers dc
comics
on est en approche
les faits
notre 7e pouvoir attention à cannes
aubin ces gamins et en difficulté dégage
mollo sur la haine la noce
le protégerait contre câble est tout
seul je peux pas faut du renfort
on va former un super méga groupe on va
refaire un tour sur linkedin
je te présente bedlam je m'appelle
shatter star domino j'ai de la chance la
chance c'est pas super pouvoir écouter
sinon d'accord
mais si on n'a qu'à couper la poire en
deux c'est non aller en piste donc
pour moi
j'ai parlé aux conséquences et qui sait
en jouer pleinement d'arc
tu es sûr que tu viens pas de l'univers
dc comics
[Musique]
oui
dis donc t'es balles elles sont rapides
maintenant pour couronner tout peter un
super pouvoir quelconque je sais pas
nager pas de pouvoir non j'ai vu
l'annoncé voilà tel poste
[Musique]